Yes, it says it's in progress.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, so we can begin.
Siamo a cominciare.
Namo tassa bhagavato hara hato samma sambuddhasa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So this evening we're looking at the Buddha, his alter ego, what he would have been if he hadn't have become a Buddha.
So if you remember, eight wise men came to his birth and predicted that he would become a Buddha or a wheel turning monarch.
Se vi ricordate, al lato della sua nascita si presentarono otto saggi, i quali dissero che sarebbe diventato un Buddha oppure colui che avrebbe girato la ruota del Dhamma.
So seven of them said that, but there was one wise person who said that he would definitely become a self-awakened Buddha.
In reality, seven gave these two options, but the eighth declared that in a certain way he would become an autorealized Buddha.
Now, his tribe, clan, was still governed in the old way.
The warrior caste chose one of themselves to become the head person or the head man.
It was an aristocracy.
I'm sure that the Brahmins had some effect and maybe the merchants.
But the essence was that somebody else could always be voted to be the head person.
Now, as one tribe became more and more powerful, they began to conquer the different tribes.
As one of these clans, one of these tribes became more and more powerful, he began to conquer all the lands and all the others, to conquer, to defeat the other tribes.
So the Buddha's own tribe, the Sakyas, were already vassals to the king of Kosala.
And we know from the way he organized the Sangha, the monks and nuns, that he didn't really like the monarchical, the autocratic,
way of ruling he didn't leave a leader when he died he just he said he left the dharma and the veneer the rule of the order
Tant'è vero che quando morì scelse prima di morire, decisi di non proclamare un successore, ma ci sarebbe stata il Dhamma, gli insegnamenti e il Vinaya, le regole di condotta.
Nel buddhismo non c'è un Papa.
So he offers us this myth about the wheel turning monarch.
So what happens is the dharma wheel appears to this particular king.
Then what happens is that this king, in particular, appears, the wheel of the dam appears.
This wheel appears and the king asks his advisers what the meaning of this appearance was.
so the counselor says well he has to follow it and as he follows it the kingdoms will just become uh vassals to him and so um
He then follows this Dhammacakka, this Dhamma wheel, and he flies off into the air with it.
And so this prince, this king obeys and follows this Dhammacakka, this wheel of the Dhamma, he flies into the air and follows it.
and he takes with him his army, which is the infantry and the archers.
Sorry, go on.
Yes, he carries with him his quadruple army, which is formed by the army, by the chariots.
uh yeah by his infantry his archers chariots and elephants now he has what's known as his seven treasures so the buddha has seven factors of enlightenment and the this uh world this this emperor has seven treasures
So the first thing, of course, is this miracle wheel which will guide him all over the world.
He has a miracle horse that can fly through the air.
He has a miracle elephant.
I don't know what that does.
And he has a gem that can cast light over a huge area, like the sun.
He has a queen who is, of course, a beautiful woman.
It is said that her limbs are cool in the hot season and warm in the cool season.
He has a wise counsellor and a successful commander.
Okay, so what actually gives him his power?
It's his moral code, his integrity.
So whenever he goes, he establishes peace.
So the Buddha then gives us his ten qualities.
So this is what the Buddha is saying, that somebody who rules a country
uh, our prime ministers and people like that should have these 10 qualities.
So the first one is generosity.
So he's very, he's very giving with his wealth and, uh, it makes people feel loyal to him.
He is extremely generous with his goods and makes people feel loyal to him.
And he sets a good example to the citizens by his ethical conduct.
And thanks to his ethical conduct, he is an example of great value, of great importance for his subjects.
and he will personally make sacrifices for the benefit of the people.
He is very honest and straightforward.
He promotes justice and trust.
He's also gentle, gentle in approach.
And so he can reduce conflicts and enhance peaceful relations.
He has self-control, self-discipline.
He doesn't indulge himself.
He doesn't give in to anger.
He remains calm.
And this makes him wise in his decisions.
He promotes harmlessness, ahimsa, ensuring safety and security.
violence, and in this way he spreads safety everywhere.
And he has patience.
He can tolerate when things don't go right.
Moreover, he is very patient, which makes him able to endure when circumstances are not favorable to him.
And well, it's a bit of a repetition, but he advocates non-conflicts and harmony.
He resolves disputes amicably.
And in this way, he maintains the unity of his kingdoms.
So it does sound that this emperor has the same qualities as the Buddha.
So what goes wrong after seven of these
great wheel turning monarchs.
But at a certain point, after seven of these emperors who followed the wheel of Dhamma, something goes wrong.
One of these Dhammacakas doesn't follow the rules of morality.
And becomes greedy.
And so people became poor.
And for the first time in a very, very long time, somebody stole something.
And for the first time in a very long time, a person committed a theft.
So he was brought to this king and the king asked him, why did you steal?
He said, well, I don't have enough money to keep my family.
And the man replied, I don't have enough money to support my family.
So the king gives him money.
But then the rumor spread around that if you stole, the king would give you money.
So people began to steal.
And after a while, the king realized he'd made a big mistake.
Greed had entered into his kingdoms.
So the next thief he had executed
So the first thief who came into his hands condemned him to death.
But this only made people more angry and the whole kingdom began to become very lawless.
This only made the people even more angry and they committed all sorts of crimes.
And the Buddha said that this would continue until the next self-awakened Buddha appeared.
And that Buddha would be called the Maitreya Buddha.
And this word comes from the word for mother.
So it's a Buddha who has a mother loving disposition.
Okay.
So just very quickly, um,
when it comes to his involvement in local politics he's he's uh he's very much uh you know ready to offer advice there was the king of magadha ajata sattu
He sent an ambassador to the Buddha to ask him if this was the right time to attack the Vajji Federation.
So the Vajji Federation was a combination of tribes who elected their own leaders.
The Buddha doesn't say yes or no, but he gives seven reasons as to why a country will remain strong.
So the first is that the Vajjis meet in harmony and leave in harmony.
And the first reason is that the Vagis meet in harmony and live in harmony.
They don't abolish existing decrees.
And I think this refers to the constitutions.
I think this refers to a form of constitution that existed.
They respect, esteem and venerate the elders.
They respect and venerate the elders.
This is a funny one.
That they do not forcibly abduct women or girls from their different clans.
And then there is the fact that they do not kidnap.
women and children to other tribes, they do not kidnap them.
That they respect and esteem their shrines.
They respect their sanctuaries.
And finally that they give shelter and security to the Arahats.
And finally they give shelter and welcome the Arahats.
So yes, when the ambassador reports this back to the king, Ajatasattu, instead he uses bribery and deceit to achieve his goals.
And at this point the king uses methods of giving money and giving speeches that divided the populations to be able to achieve his goal.
A lot of fake news.
Yes, he gives false news, he tells false news that puts these tribes against each other.
yes and they eventually begin to quarrel and uh he just walks in and takes over the country yeah so here we have an occasion where the buddha is intimately involved in what is happening in the society around him
And there are many other incidents.
So, since we ourselves are trying to behave like a Buddha,
it means that we ought to also become involved in the politics economics of the day so in this way the buddha is our exemplar
So this is the Buddha's alter ego.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
Sorry, can you repeat?
I hope my words have been of some assistance.
Spero che le mie parole siano stati utili.
That I have not caused confusion.
Che non ho creato confusione in nessuno di voi.
And that you will by following the example of the Buddha become fully liberated from all suffering.
E che seguendo l'esempio del Buddha possiate essere liberati completamente da ogni sofferenza.
Sooner rather than later.
Meglio prima che poi.
So we can sit for a little while and then we will do the refuges and precepts.
And we can sit for a while and then we will take refuge in the precepts.